[Music]
in 1800 the Explorer Alexander von
Humboldt witnessed a swarm of electric
eels leap out of the water to defend
themselves against oncoming horses most
people thought the story so unusual that
Humboldt made it up but fish using
electricity is more common than you
might think
and yes electric eels are a type of fish
underwater where light is scarce
electrical signals offer ways to
communicate navigate and find plus in
rare cases stun prey nearly 350 species
of fish have specialized anatomical
structures that generate and detect
electrical signals these fish are
divided into two groups depending on how
much electricity they produce scientists
call the first group the weekly electric
fish structures near their tails called
electric organs produce up to a volt of
electricity about two-thirds as much as
a double-a battery how does this work
the fish's brain sends a signal through
its nervous system to the electric organ
which is filled with stacks of hundreds
or thousands of disc-shaped cells called
electrocytes normally electrocytes pump
out sodium and potassium ions to
maintain a positive charge outside and
negative charge inside but when the
nerve signal arrives at the electro site
it prompts the ion gates to open
positively charged ions flow back in now
one face of the electrolyte is
negatively charged outside and
positively charged inside but the far
side has the opposite charge pattern
these alternating charges can drive a
current turning the electro site into a
biological battery the key to these
fishes powers is that nerve signals are
coordinated to arrive at each cell at
exactly the same time
that makes the stacks of electrocytes
act like thousands of batteries in
series the tiny charges from each one
add up to an electrical field that can
travel several meters cells called
electro receptors buried in the skin
allow the fish to constantly sense this
field and the changes to it caused by
the surroundings or other fish the
Peters elephant nose fish for example
has an elongated chin call - Nelson
Oregon that's riddled in electro
receptors that allows it to intercept
signals from other fish the judge
distances detect the shape and size of
nearby objects and even determine
whether a buried insect is dead or alive
but the elephant nose and other weakly
electric fish don't produce enough
electricity to attack their prey that
ability belongs to the strongly electric
fish of which there are only a handful
of species the most powerful strongly
electric fish is the electric knife fish
more commonly known as the electric eel
three electric organs span almost its
entire 2 meter body like the weakly
electric fish the electric eel uses its
signals to navigate and communicate but
it reserves its strongest electric
discharges for hunting using a two-phase
attack that suss is out and then
incapacitates its prey first it emits
two or three strong pulses as much as
600 volts these stimulate the preys
muscles sending it into spasms and
generating waves that reveal its hiding
place then a volley of fast high-voltage
discharges causes even more intense
muscle contractions the electric eel can
also curl up so that the electric fields
generated at each end of the electric
organ overlap the electrical storm
eventually exhausts and immobilizes the
prey and the electric eel can swallow
its meal alive
the other two strongly electric fish are
the electric catfish which can unleash
350 volts with an electric organ that
occupies most of its torso and the
electric ray with kidney-shaped electric
organs on either side of its head
that produce as much as two hundred and
twenty volts there is one mystery in the
world of electric fish
why don't they electrocute themselves it
may be that the size of strongly
electric fish allows them to withstand
their own shocks or that the current
passes out of their bodies too quickly
some scientists think that special
proteins may shield the electric organs
but the truth is this is one mystery
science still hasn't illuminated Ted
Edie is a non-profit if you value our
work please consider supporting it on
patreon.com slash Ted Edie
[Music]